introduction
life is short
you can if you work hard and are lucky
get more of almost anything but you
can't get more time
time only goes one way
the average american has a lifespan of
less than thirty thousand days
so how you choose to live matters
that's the topic of this book
i don't pretend to have all the answers
i'm still learning every day and many of
the good ideas here i've picked up from
other people either directly or by
reading
but this is what's worked for me
like life this book is short
many books i read could communicate
their ideas in fewer pages
so i've tried to be brief in line with
the wise person who noted if i'd had
more time i would have written a shorter
letter
i don't think brevity implies lack of
content
the concepts here have improved the
quality of my life and i hope they're
useful to you as well
using these concepts i have created a
life i love
my job doesn't feel like work
i love and respect the people with whom
i spend time
and i'm also passionate about my life
outside work
i've learned how to create a balance
that makes me happy between work and
other interests including my family
friends and exercise
sadly i think that's rare
and yet while i know i'm lucky most
people can work towards those goals in
their own lives
my interest in making the most of my
life began when i was just starting
college
but when i was in my mid-30s a boss i
admired died of cancer
he was young
he had a great wife he had three young
children he had a fantastic career he
had everything in life he just didn't
have enough time
so while i'd often thought about how to
get the most out of life the death of
someone so young and vital increased my
sense of urgency to act on it
one of the things i've always wanted to
do was to work for myself
as a result i left an exciting job at
microsoft in 2001 amidst the internet
bust to found the investing firm i now
run
it was hard to do both financially and
emotionally
when i left microsoft many people
friends family and even some of the
press thought i was deluding myself to
start a fun focus on internet related
companies during a market crash
a press quote from the time said calling
a little crazy
call in a little nuts
[Music]
i'd never seen that type of coverage
before
and in a sense the press was right the
business wasn't easy to start
fortunately from a vantage point of 10
years down the road it's worked out
quite well
a key part of my job is reading and
thinking about a broad variety of topics
so writing this book was relatively easy
it's even easier to read
but like many things in life actually
executing each day on these concepts is
extremely difficult
with thanks to thomas edison life is one
percent inspiration and 99 perspiration
even so i hope you have fun perspiring
create space
life moves pretty fast
if you don't stop to look around once in
a while you could miss it
from the movie ferris bueller's day off
we all approach life in different ways
some ways allow more time to think to be
creative to do what's important and to
spend time with friends
i'll give you an example
a friend of mine used to be the ceo of a
well-known internet company
he once told me he found it funny that
the busiest people on his team were
always the people to whom he could give
more work while the ones who
accomplished less had little time for
anything often including their existing
responsibilities
i found this is an important observation
it's often the most successful people i
know who are most efficient with their
time and who always seem to have time to
think and to do more
the trick is people who are most
productive tend to say no to things that
are unimportant to them and focus on
what they believe matters
when you think about it how could it be
any other way
of course activity by itself doesn't
equal accomplishment and certainly not
success being busy just means being busy
i know many people who work super hard
to fill up the spaces in their lives so
they won't have to think
a wise colleague calls this numbing out
they may accomplish their goals but
they're unlikely to be fulfilled or do
truly creative work
i know other people who fill their free
time with meaningless activities
they're also busy but they neither
achieve much nor are they satisfied
in contrast i once had a smart boss who
told me if i wanted to do my best work i
needed to do fewer things and really
focus on what mattered
that was great advice
many people confuse want with have to
in other words just because someone else
wants you to do something doesn't mean
you have to do it
you can't get more time so how you spend
the time you have is critical
focusing on what matters means saying no
to things that don't matter
otherwise your life becomes cluttered
with distractions
technology presents both potential
distractions and also great
opportunities to use your time better
technology is a tool
used properly it can help you but like
any other tool it can be mismanaged
if for example
you spend most of your day responding to
email or text messages or checking out
your friends on social networks you
won't get much done
a better approach is to decide what you
want to do and what is most important
make lists
then use technology to assist you versus
allowing it to control you
to execute on this concept requires
discipline and practice but anyone can
get better at it and make real progress
if they want to
one way i like to use technology to save
time is where appropriate to eliminate
meetings and use email instead
i should emphasize where appropriate
email does a terrible job of conveying
subtle emotional content so meetings are
more appropriate for teen building for
negotiating for personal conversations
and for any other situation where it's
important to look someone in the eye
but for some things email is better
mobile devices provide a fantastic way
to stay connected and on top of work
wherever you may be
if you have any downtime you can read
books or articles check email or browse
the web from virtually anywhere
distractions have increased for reasons
beyond new technologies
according to the bureau of labor
statistics about sixty percent of u s
families are two-income households
compared with only about one-third in
the mid-sixties the statistics are
directionally similar in much of the
western world
we're busier and consequently are
tempted to do lots of things at once
a number of people i know claim to be
great multitaskers
the brain however doesn't work that way
instead it focuses on one activity at a
time
if you switch back and forth between
multiple tasks your brain works more
slowly than it would if you focused on
each activity for a period of time
albert einstein said it's not that i'm
so smart it's just that i stay with
problems longer
most of us do the opposite with
predictable results
to allow yourself time to think there
are many non-technological tricks to
managing information
all of them require you to make choices
to focus your energy
i like to set aside blocks of time for
specific activities even to read or chat
that being said there are combinations
of activities which work together and
can make you more productive
for example i frequently ride an indoor
bicycle while reading since the indoor
bicycle takes no mental attention and it
allows me to get exercise at the same
time
don't try to do the same thing though on
an outdoor bike
another way to free up time if you have
the option is to live close to work
for many people the amount of time spent
commuting is huge and it tends to be
quite stressful and frequently not super
productive
there are usually good reasons people
want to live far from work it's often
significantly cheaper and the schools
may be better
but if you think about the value of your
time it might not make sense
you might be able to afford a smaller
home closer to your job rather than a
bigger one with a long commute
and if you do that you might have
significantly less stress on a daily
basis
in fact when i lived in manhattan
frequently the most relaxing part of my
day was walking to and from my office
it didn't seem like a sacrifice to have
a tiny apartment on the third floor of a
building without an elevator
the ultimate reduction in commuting time
is working from home something that is
becoming increasingly possible for many
people given the evolution of technology
and the desire of companies to get the
most out of their employees while
limiting real estate costs
if you have a job which accommodates it
are self-motivated and have the space
and quiet required to work well from
home it can make life considerably more
pleasant and can create more
discretionary time
a handful of my colleagues work from
home
they all love it none would choose to
work in an office again
making space in your life by using time
efficiently also helps nurture
creativity
i find it interesting that people who
tend to be the most creative have three
things in common
they're incredibly well prepared in
their fields they become masters of
their domains by practicing for many
years day after day
they spend time deeply focused on
solving a key problem or key set of
problems no matter the obstacles
they allow themselves to step away from
the problems on which they're focused so
that insights can come to them in
activities such as walking or looking
out on a beautiful scene
to get great insights absolutely
requires hard work but it also requires
space
this is the case because the human mind
is not a linear machine
if you don't put in the required effort
you won't be capable of generating good
ideas you won't understand the subject
matter
but if you don't give yourself space
from the problems on which you are
working you likely will be so worn down
you won't generate creative insights
you need both
in taking walks these days i try to
notice the beauty around me it helps me
think and relax
in fact i regularly take pictures with
my cell phone camera some are included
here as a reminder to stop and look
it's a simple thing and my pictures
won't win any prizes but it works
so to make the most of your life say no
to things that don't matter work hard at
what you love and occasionally take time
away from your core focus to rest so
that your mind can be quiet for great
insights to come
looking out to the olympic mountains
washington
try not to worry
if you can't sleep then get up and do
something instead of lying there
worrying
it's the worry that gets you not the
lack of sleep
dale carnegie
worrying i've found wastes energy and
wastes time it limits what you can
accomplish
i try not to obsess on the past but to
learn from it
i try not to worry about the future but
to prepare for it
and while it's difficult sometimes i try
to take pleasure in the moment even when
bad things happen
an inspirational woman i know is cancer
yet she finds the beauty in every day
and every moment
i don't know many people who are more
positive or go through life with as much
curiosity or energy as she does
the last time i saw her was at a dinner
party she was more engaged than anyone
else that evening constantly asking
questions about new technology and how i
thought it would change the world
i also have several friends with
multiple sclerosis and they live more
restricted and more painful lives than
most of us but each seems excited every
time we meet
they're clearly trying to get the most
out of their limited time left on earth
the lesson to me is that you can focus
on something going well or something
beautiful or something interesting even
amidst terrible times
i try to put things into two buckets one
i can do something about and one i can't
the things i can't do anything about i
try to ignore
there's no use for example being jealous
of other people's success or good luck
it won't make me any happier
nor is there any upside in worrying
about a bad situation in which i find
myself
there is however a lot to be gained from
considering how i can move to a better
place
i've also noticed it helps to accept the
world as it is not in a sense that you
can't change things although that is
sometimes the case but in a sense that
you need to see reality clearly before
you can take effective action as a
professor of mine once said if you think
the table you are sitting at will fly
you have a problem
except that luck and bad luck aren't
evenly or fairly distributed and you
can't do anything about that
i have many talented friends in the
technology industry who've been paid
over the years primarily in stock
options
some have made a great deal of money
this way and frequently they were just
lucky to have joined a given company at
a certain time
they weren't necessarily more talented
than others
they didn't work harder or contribute
more than people who started later than
they did
they frequently didn't even have a
strong conviction in advance that they'd
make a lot of money although they knew
there was a chance they might
they were relative to their peers lucky
there are some things in life you can't
change such as your parents your height
or the personalities of other adults
for the problems you can impact and you
want to alter think about what you want
to accomplish and try to do that in a
pragmatic way
you don't have to change everything
overnight
in fact thinking you can or should is
likely to lead to failure or to feeling
overwhelmed and as a result perhaps
doing nothing
my experience the last 10 years
illustrates this point if i tried to
build my investing business to scale in
a short time frame or worried when stock
prices declined i would have failed
i started investing immediately before
september
11th while prices of internet stocks
then were low relative to their business
value prices dropped significantly for
another year and a half during the
internet bust before recovering to
sensible levels
i had no idea that would happen
it didn't feel pleasant
my family lost faith in me and most of
my friends thought i was a bit nuts to
even invest in the sector
it was only because i stayed focused on
understanding the businesses in which
i'd invested and was willing to stick
with my convictions over a matter of
years that my ideas worked out well
over time other people gained faith in
my investing abilities but it didn't
happen overnight
it wasn't easy
and nothing i might have done early on
would have changed that
lastly when you make mistakes along the
way as i have at many points in my life
accept them as well
i've tried to learn from my mistakes
their experience and they're the sort of
experience you won't soon forget
as winston churchill said success is not
final failure is not fatal it is the
courage to continue that counts
sunset from the air somewhere over
western canada
don't do really dumb things
all i want to know is where i'm going to
die so i'll never go there charlie
monger
you can't follow charlie munger's advice
literally
but as a wise colleague of mine says
sometimes the most important thing to do
is to not do anything really dumb i
found this type of inactivity is
undervalued in our culture
many investors overlook avoiding dumb
mistakes
warren buffett suggests people approach
investing the same way ted williams
looked at batting only swing at the
pitches in the center of your strike
zone
since there are no called strikes in
investing you should let the others go
by
this sounds easy to do and you'd think
most investors would behave this way but
they don't
when many people buy stocks they tend to
think more about the potential upside
than what they might lose if things
don't go well
by pivoting that thinking and avoiding
really dumb ideas and investing in
business and in life you'll approach
problems from a wholly different
perspective
i've used the same mental model to try
to avoid too much debt drinking too much
staying away from people who are bad
influences eating poorly and not
exercising
i should probably make the distinction
here between really dumb things and
routine mistakes made in the course of
your life
the latter as i've noted are certainly
painful but inescapable and useful
learning
what do i mean then by really dumb
things
there are two classes unrecoverable
errors in denial
unrecoverable errors can screw up your
future like committing a crime and going
to prison or limiting your options by
not trying to get the best education
available or making decisions which
likely will lead to major health
problems or financial destruction
as an extreme example i know someone who
as a child accidentally shot his sibling
the sibling never fully recovered and
the accidental shooter never overcame
his guilt
as a result his life has been ruined
there are many things that are not
nearly as dramatic but can have a
similarly negative long-term impact
what you choose to do each day matters
habits form when we're young and
solidify before we know it
so forming the right habits early is
critical whether that means eating well
exercising saving money or being honest
as a wise investor i know likes to say
people become more so over time
the second class of dumb thing denial is
common
most of us ignore reality in some facet
of our lives
it's often easier to believe things will
somehow solve themselves whether we want
a lousy job to work out or we're so
desperate to hire someone for a much
needed role we sacrifice on quality or
we overlook obvious issues in someone
we're dating and assume they'll get
better over time or we can help fix them
these are all examples of wishful
thinking
if you notice serious problems in the
early stages of a job or in the hiring
process they're only likely to become
magnified as you get to know the
situation or your new colleague better
ditto and dating
small problems early on generally don't
just resolve themselves with time
and it's impossible to change other
adults personalities no matter what you
may wish
a well-known joke illustrates the point
the biggest mistake men make when they
think about getting married is they
assume women won't change the biggest
mistake women make is they assume they
can change men
the same warning about wishful thinking
is true with exercise and pain
if you start feeling pain while
exercising it's the body's way of
telling you to stop
if you battle through it as many of us
do frequently you'll make the injury
worse
so how can you avoid really dumb things
i try to rely on my gut instincts
whenever i feel that something might
have a really bad outcome i pay
attention to that feeling
feelings aren't always correct we fear
many things we have little reason to be
concerned about in the modern world but
feelings can flag problems that may be
difficult to articulate
proceeding when there are obvious issues
is a dumb thing to do
even if it's inconvenient or painful
i've learned i'm better off doing
nothing when the only available choice
has glaring issues
snowshoeing in whistler bc
build character and make friends
abraham lincoln said character is like a
tree and reputation like its shadow
the shadow is what we think of it the
tree is the real thing
character i've found is one of the most
important things in life
reputations can be manipulated in the
short term but people tend to get the
reputations they deserve over time
reputations are your personal brand
they're influential in how well you do
in both your professional and personal
lives
there are four basic principles that
have worked well for me
do what you think is right
don't follow other people blindly
be honest and keep your word
admit your mistakes
if you live your life authentically keep
your word admit mistakes and admit what
you don't know you'll find people will
trust you more over time and you'll
become wiser too
when i entered college i thought most
people would adopt similar principles
but i found that a lot of people succumb
to peer pressure and other external
forces
i've met lots of smart people who work
very hard
i've met substantially fewer who are
also authentic and have integrity
i try to spend my time with the second
group
and generally i've found that those
people are happy and have more real
friends
inevitably we take on some of the habits
of people with whom we're closest
the people with whom we associate can
have a huge impact on the development of
our personalities particularly when
we're young
in that light if you have children try
to be sure their peer groups are healthy
ones
their peers likely will have more
influence on the development of your
kids personalities than you will
if that sounds absurd look at how
immigrants kids develop in a
non-immigrant community they nearly
always seem to speak act and have the
values of their peers and not their
immigrant parents
my son for instance has a friend whose
parents recently emigrated from japan
and moved to canada
my son's friend doesn't like japanese
food his favorite things to eat include
steak and hamburger and he acts and
speaks much more like his classmates and
friends than he does his japanese
parents
in your own life think about the values
and habits you want to have and then
ensure you choose your friends
colleagues mentors and bosses carefully
my friends and mentors have made a huge
difference in my life both
professionally and personally
for example i was able to succeed as an
investor in the early years because a
super smart mentor was willing to share
his knowledge with me and encouraged me
to have faith in my convictions
i'm eternally grateful
similarly in my personal life when i
spend time with people i respect like
and care about i usually feel great
to build trusting friendships i've
learned it's critical to be true to my
passions and express how i feel and what
i want
if i weren't open and honest i wonder
what sort of friends i'd have
this matters
real friends people you trust respect
laugh with and can rely on are a vitally
important part of life
no matter how much wealth or fame you
accumulate if you don't have true
friends it's unlikely you'll be
happy sadly i know too many people who
have achieved their material goals but
have no friends
as the expression goes greed is a hole
you can never fill though there are
definitely a lot of people who
try warren buffett refers to rose
blumkin a woman who escaped the nazis
before immigrating to america and
founding nebraska furniture mart as
having the ultimate standard for
friendship
ms blanken apparently said she had a
hard time making friends
she would ask herself if the nazis were
to return would a particular person hide
her
now that's a super high standard but you
can imagine how much richer and easier
your life would be with even a handful
of true friends like that
view of husky stadium university of
washington
care for yourself and others
lack of activity destroys the good
condition of every human being while
movement and methodical physical
exercise save it and preserve it
plato
our bodies were designed by evolution to
thrive on the african savannah
twenty 000 years ago people didn't sit
in forests or caves staring at computer
screens talking on telephones or
watching television
we were made to move and our brains were
made to think while in motion
so if you want to feel good be as
productive as possible live longer
reduce stress be more creative and be
happier than you need to exercise
regularly
when i was at microsoft i used to run
for about eight minutes every morning
before heading to the office
that's not nearly enough and i slowly
got out of shape
i now take an hour at lunch to bike play
tennis run or even walk
over the last 10 years i've lost about
20 pounds and i'm more alert and
creative
the extra time invest in an exercise has
been worth it even if only measured from
a professional standpoint
our bodies also weren't designed to eat
junk food all day
thousands of years ago getting calories
was tough we like sweets and fats now
because it was tremendous work getting
them men and we never knew when our next
meal would come
while our genetic desires for sweet and
fatty foods haven't changed modern
western civilization with its easy and
rapid access to supermarkets processed
and generally inexpensive food has
removed the natural barriers that stop
us from eating what we want
i've always been a fairly healthy eater
although i love desserts but one small
trick i've adopted is to try to eat
dinner early
i found that just doing that helps keep
me at a healthy weight
and when i eat dinner a bit later i try
to take a walk afterwards
i recognize that's uncommon
the result of less exercise and more
food is not pleasant
as a society we're getting fat
we're creating many health issues and
costs which we'll have to deal with down
the road
another critical element of taking care
of yourself is getting a good amount of
sleep on a regular basis
i try to organize my schedule to ensure
i sleep well since i've learned i
perform best when i'm well rested
for instance when i travel to different
time zones i alter my schedule days
ahead of time so it's more closely
aligned with where i'm going
i've found that earplugs are also
wonderful tools for hotel rooms if you
don't know it will be quiet
if you can manage to sleep well no
matter where you are you'll find you
have more energy and are able to think
more clearly
stay active
people are like sharks if we don't move
constantly we'll die
this is true both literally and
metaphorically
for example there's some evidence
suggesting that older people who keep
their minds active have a much lower
chance of getting alzheimer's disease
people who retire and mostly eat and lie
on the couch aren't likely to live very
long or be very happy
taking care of yourself extends beyond
your body to your mental health
many people don't feel good about
themselves psychologically
this may start in childhood when their
parents may not give them enough care
and attention so they don't feel lovable
or they may get too much too easily from
their parents so they end up feeling
undeserving
or their parents may be overly critical
nothing is ever good enough so they end
up constantly trying to please other
people or feeling inadequate or both
regardless it's important as an adult no
matter what type of parents you had that
you take responsibility for your life
it's only by loving celebrating and
appreciating what makes you unique that
you can fully enjoy your life and truly
love others if you don't love yourself
the results are pleasant
for instance a number of people i know
spend money in unhealthy ways sometimes
running up large amounts of debt by
buying things they believe will make
them feel better
sadly but predictably it doesn't work
the pleasant feeling of owning something
new soon fades and then they're on to
buying the next thing
the debt potentially incurred by this
sort of activity not only causes
financial difficulties but may also lead
to health issues
given the increase in two income
families over the last 30 years you
might think that people would be better
off
that's not the case
people in the u.s and much of the
western world tend to spend more of what
they earn than they did a generation ago
they may do this to keep up with their
friends or what they think is expected
of them in our society but that's not a
treadmill you want to be on
people also compensate for not feeling
good about themselves by overeating
drinking too much overworking and
becoming reliant on constant or
unhealthy sex to numb their pain
all of these are addictions
taking care of yourself means finding a
balance that works for you then having
the discipline to maintain that balance
if you want help there are many people
including some good therapists who can
be a great resource to discuss issues
that are important to you
mark twain said grief can take care of
itself but to get the full value of a
joy you must have somebody to divide it
with
there are innumerable serious problems
in the world and there are huge numbers
of people who'd love your help
you've doubtless heard that message many
times before particularly around the
holidays
but if you need motivation to help
others i can tell you from personal
experience you will directly benefit
few things make you feel better about
yourself
i get great joy out of helping at my
kids school from helping friends with
their business problems and from doing a
good job investing
if i do my job well my friends and
clients will be able to send their kids
to college to retire without financial
worries and to do things that are
important to them
you don't need to look far to help other
people
for example taking the interests of
children seriously encouraging and
supporting them as well as setting high
standards can make a big difference in
their lives
almost anyone can be a father or a
mother but being a good parent takes
hard work focus and a great deal of
caring
despite the obvious sacrifices of time
and resources i've found being a parent
has been the most satisfying and
enriching experience i've ever had
most parents i know would say similar
things
there are many ways to make a difference
in the world you can help your extended
family help friends help your community
or help people you don't even know
you can help one-on-one or in small
groups or if you have the ability or
resources on a larger scale
so long as it works for you it doesn't
matter
when you're in your 80s and looking back
on your life i have little doubt you'll
feel better if you have chosen to give
something back our time on earth is
limited but you can extend your
influence by helping those who will
outlive you
guadabalone paris
laugh
abraham lincoln said with the fearful
strain that is on me night and day if i
did not laugh i should die
while your life will hopefully end
better than lincoln's it won't always go
your way guaranteed
within the constraints of your genetic
wiring it's up to you how you deal with
that
you may not have the parents or the
siblings you have chosen
you may not look the way you'd have
picked
the people you love may not always love
you back
you may not live where you'd like
you may not have the job you want or get
the promotion you believe you deserve
if you get married it may not work out
the way you thought it would
if you have children they won't always
do what you'd like and they may
disappoint you sometimes
i've found you can choose to let all the
things that go wrong in life depress you
or you can accept that things will go
wrong try to laugh and then look at what
you can do
there's a japanese proverb that gets
right to the point we're fools whether
we dance or not so we might as well
dance
i remember an important business meeting
i had about 15 years ago at microsoft
it was clear that the problem we faced
was unpleasant and wasn't going away
after a few minutes of intense
discussion the most senior person in the
room laughed and said i guess we're
screwed
it shocked me but that frankness and dry
humor immediately stopped the discussion
and we moved on to discussing things we
could impact
a sense of humor is also useful when you
make mistakes
i still remember an experience i had
during college when i worked as an
intern for the mcniel slash lira report
a pbs television news show
one of my duties was to greet guests at
the door
one day i went downstairs to meet thomas
keane then governor of new jersey
as i got to the guard desk in the lobby
a man walked up and told the guard his
name was tom keane and that he was there
to go to the mcneil slash lira report
i introduced myself and proceeded to
take him to the green room to be made up
he kept telling me to stop calling him
governor and call him tom
he also said he wanted to go upstairs to
meet a reporter
i told him we didn't have much time so
he could call the reporter from the
green room
when we got there seated in the makeup
chair he called the reporter and said
would you please tell this guy that i'm
your boyfriend tom keane and not the
governor of new jersey
i was embarrassed immediately apologized
and ran back to the lobby to meet
governor thomas king of new jersey who
stood flanked by two huge state troopers
i remember laughing at myself as i told
governor keem the story on the elevator
back up to the green room
it's sobering to note that whether
you're able to laugh when things go
badly may be an inborn trait
a famous study was done using two groups
of people paraplegics and lottery
winners
the study looked at these two groups
happiness before their life-changing
events immediately following them and
then also a bit later the immediate
effect was predictable people who became
paraplegics got depressed and people who
won the lottery were elated
but after a relatively short period of
time both groups returned to their
original levels of happiness paraplegics
who'd been happy before their injuries
became happy paraplegics lottery winners
who'd been unhappy and bitter before
their windfalls became unhappy bitter
lottery winners
i know several personal stories
including friends who lost a child in a
terrible accident the most horrible
thing i can imagine that illustrate the
same principle some people can laugh
even amidst terrible times
the payoff is the physical act of
laughing actually improves your mood
assuming your basic life needs are being
met you can choose to be happy if you
want even when you make mistakes or are
in the middle of some pretty awful
circumstances if however you're the sort
of person who chooses to be unhappy or
filled with anxiety chances are you'll
probably succeed with that as well
in thinking about this i keep mark twain
in mind the fear of death follows from
the fear of life
a man who lives fully is prepared to die
at any time
sunset at the edge of the glass mountain
range west texas
do what you love
jean de la bruyer said there are but
three events in a man's life birth life
and death
he is not conscious of being born he
dies in pain and he forgets to live
how many movies have you seen where the
hero or heroine quits a job they hate to
pursue their life dreams
these movies wouldn't be made and they
wouldn't resonate with so many people if
they didn't contain an important desire
that most people deny themselves
a lot of apparently successful people
believe they should delay enjoying life
until later
first they work incredibly hard to get
into the right schools then they work
even harder to get a coveted job and
then they work harder still for years to
get to a certain position or make a
certain amount of money
the net of this whole adventure is that
frequently it's not until late in life
when a person's health may be going and
a lot of their life is behind them that
they stop to think about what they want
and by then there may not be much they
can do about it
they can't recover the time
and many people don't even stop to think
oliver wendell holmes noted many people
die with their music still in them
why is this so
too often it is because they are always
getting ready to live
before they know it time runs out
when i was growing up someone told me to
live as if i was going to die in 10
years and had no immediate financial
needs
that's great advice
if you can do that you'll be happier and
more successful
to figure out what you want to do you
need to know yourself
if you like yourself about who you are
or hide your identity from others it
will inevitably create stress and it's
unlikely you'll be either productive or
happy
part of knowing yourself means
acknowledging what you genuinely want
if you focus on what other people expect
of you you may impress your friends
family and colleagues but it's unlikely
you'll be satisfied with yourself over
the long term
you need to understand your values and
your priorities
for example some people value income
more than others while other people
place greater importance on the sense of
meaning they find in a job
although what makes you passionate
generally doesn't change over time what
you want to do sometimes does
when i was young i didn't know what i
wanted to do i always liked to read but
not necessarily the books that were
assigned by my teachers
when i was about 18 i decided i wanted
to be a journalist
i always loved learning and i thought
being a journalist would be a great way
to stay informed about the world
after working as a journalist in college
i found i liked many aspects of the job
but i didn't think it was the perfect
fit for me
i tried other careers through my 20s and
30s searching for something that felt
right
i started a small business which
eventually folded for lack of funding
i went back to business school
then i worked for two big corporations
in two very different industries time
incorporated and microsoft
i succeeded at some jobs and i failed in
aspects of others
i enjoyed a few jobs a great deal and
was lucky to make some lifelong friends
along the way
it wasn't until i was in my late
thirties when i started to work for
myself investing that i finally found a
career which drew on all of my natural
curiosity had few aspects to it that i
didn't enjoy and basically didn't feel
like work
fortunately everything i'd done earlier
in my career wasn't wasted
in fact many of the experiences i had
had and particularly my failures became
useful learning
while it's obviously better to start
doing what you love early in life many
people don't
tom clancy the author of numerous
exciting and commercially successful
books including the hunt for red october
became a writer when he was in his
thirties after a career in the insurance
business
john grisham the author of many great
legal stories was an attorney and a
local politician before his first book a
time to kill was published when he was
about 33.
ronald reagan wasn't elected to public
office until he was 55. earlier in life
he'd been an actor and a union official
and though few have heard of alfred
wallace merchant and fishermen art
lovers know that alfred wallace the
painter emerged in his late sixties
after his wife died
so it's quite possible to reinvent your
career even late in life
all of these people successfully evolved
their careers toward doing something
they loved
but why is that important
there are three primary reasons
we spend huge amounts of our lives
working if you work from the time you're
20 until you're 65 five days a week and
a great many of us work far more than
that then you will work for at least
half your adult life
we also live in a super competitive
world
it's likely the only way you'll stand
out at what you do is if you work very
hard for long periods of time
it's said that to become an expert in a
given activity requires about ten
thousand hours of practice
at forty hours a week doing nothing else
which is extremely unlikely it takes
five years of solid work to master a
subject
and i've found the only way people have
the stamina to outwork others year after
year is when they love what they do
sadly most people don't have jobs they
truly love
instead they often work an unsatisfying
jobs sometimes because they have no
choice but sometimes to impress others
but three window offices fancy titles
awards and more stuff don't bring
happiness
some people never get this
i was recently chatting with a guy i met
who'd been quite successful
i said i'd been in new york on 9 11 and
had heard through a friend he was
supposed to have been at the top of the
world trade center that day but that he
fortunately cancelled last minute
he corrected me actually i was supposed
to be the keynote speaker at an
important event at the world trade
center on 9 11.
i was stunned he'd almost died in a
spectacular catastrophe that impacted
millions of people and yet years later
in telling the story he tried to impress
me with the status of his job
i told him i thought he was just lucky
to be alive
there's a lesson here
for people who have a choice between
jobs there are frequently two broad
options
option one is doing what you love every
day but not earning as much money as you
might otherwise and are not having as
much prestige in the eyes of your
acquaintances
option two is doing a job you hate or
find boring but either the job itself or
the money you can make from the job
impresses other folks
to me the choice is clear
what i find a bit shocking is that many
people choose option two and stick with
it over the course of their careers
many other people enter fields they love
but over time forget what they love
about their work and prioritize the
external recognition they receive from
it
while there's nothing wrong with being
well paid and we all love to receive
praise for good work prioritizing
external rewards over the work itself is
a failing strategy
it's just anecdotal data but everyone i
know who works primarily to impress
other people is unhappy or unfulfilled
regardless of how extremely successful
they may seem
almost everyone i know well who works
passionately at a job for its own sake
is happy and most have been successful
so the question is how do you determine
what you passionately want to do
i'll share my own experience
before i left microsoft i took out a
piece of paper and listed those moments
in my life i loved most
i tried to identify patterns
with that information and a bit of
research about various career options i
picked something which i thought would
allow me to do what made me most happy
i also paid close attention using the
same method to things i didn't like to
do and worked hard to eliminate those
things from my life
you can use this system at any point in
your career but you may have to serve as
an apprentice for several years early on
doing less than fun things in order to
learn the ropes
that's just part of the journey assuming
you work with people you respect
i developed a litmus test for job
satisfaction that might resonate with
you
when i was in a job i hated i noticed on
sunday nights or returning from
vacations i actually felt sick
today because my work and personal life
are highly integrated i work over the
weekends but i feel just as excited
sunday night as i do on friday afternoon
ideally you want a job you'd do even if
you weren't paid to do it
that's not an economic reality for most
of us but it's the right goal to shoot
for
if you can get paid to do what you
perceive as play you have a great job
finally focus on your present situation
and your future goals
people like to strive to achieve
something new if you are a mountain
climber as a good friend of mine is you
always look for the next peak
those who live in the past tend to be
unhappy
no matter how significant your past
accomplishments may be they won't keep
you satisfied
a former classmate's greatest days were
at school nearly 30 years ago
he went to a wonderful and prestigious
school and was a bit of a star there
these days he tries to attend as many
reunions as he can
but you can't live life backwards and
he's unfulfilled in his current life
freud said love and work are the
cornerstones of our humanness
while it may sound simple if you have
close friendships and love your work the
odds are quite high that you'll be happy
most of the time
embrace change
w edwards deming said it is not
necessary to change
survival is not mandatory
change will happen whether you like it
or not
in fact given technologies evolution and
globalization there's little doubt that
the rate of change is accelerating
this can be disconcerting we tend to
hate change
we prefer to know what will happen
however if you fight change you'll
usually lose and you'll get worn down
fighting it i recall meeting with some
folks in the newspaper in yellow pages
industries in the mid 90s
i told them the internet would reshape
their world but they were making good
money on their print business and had
been doing that for many years
in fact most of them had monopolies
where they could pretty much charge
whatever they wanted
so overall they basically ignored the
internet they did little things here and
there but nothing fundamental
it didn't impact their near-term
earnings
five years later nothing had happened to
those businesses
after ten years the internet started
encroaching on their profits
and then very quickly the internet title
wave decimated them
to be clear a small number of these
companies may still adapt and survive
but had they viewed what was happening
in the world with open eyes and started
making meaningful changes to their
businesses in the mid 90s i'd bet a lot
of money some of them would be in a
dramatically different place today
this pattern of ignoring change is not
new
alexander graham bell said
when one door closes another door opens
but we so often look so long and so
regretfully upon the closed door that we
do not see the ones which open for us
the same is true in personal
relationships
if you fight change it simply won't work
people fall out of love they age their
needs and desires change
if you embrace inevitable change you'll
be ahead of the pack
if a relationship isn't working don't
just give up
but if you have tried hard to fix it
over time and can't do anything about it
then it's important to recognize you may
need to make a change in your life the
lesson i've learned is this since change
is inevitable the key is learning how to
manage it
if you deal with issues immediately and
don't let them faster they won't become
bigger and ultimately unmanageable
problems are much easier to deal with
when they're still small than if you've
let them grow over time
at some points in your life you may try
to drive change
in those instances i've found patience
is a huge virtue
change comes slowly
it's a hard thing to accept and people
may resist it actively or passively
in fact in some fields such as internet
adoption change often doesn't come until
people leave their jobs and are replaced
by a new generation
this principle holds true well beyond
the technology sector
upper west side of manhattan and the
jacqueline kennedy onassis reservoir
learn from experience
albert einstein said the definition of
insanity is doing the same thing over
and over again and expecting different
results
while i've met many people who focus on
being smart and working hard i know few
people who regularly focus on learning
from their own experience and the
experience of others
i've noticed that if you are one of
those few who try to learn every day it
makes a huge difference over long
periods of time
many people act like the guy in the
story who went to the movies with his
friend
the guy says to his friend i bet the
cowboy falls off his horse at the end of
the movie and dies
his friend takes the bet
the cowboy indeed falls off his horse
and dies
the guy says to his friend i don't
understand why you bet me
we saw the movie last week
the friend says well i didn't think he'd
be dumb enough to do it again
it's a funny story and it seems
ridiculous
and yet i've seen many people over the
years do essentially the same thing
they ignore clear lessons from their
experience or the experience of others
if you want to learn from experience
i've found the following useful
be curious
kids naturally are curious and they are
able to learn and progress at very rapid
rates
i've tried to maintain my natural
curiosity as i've gotten older and i've
found my life as more interesting as a
result
read widely
there's so much wisdom written down and
it's easier not to mention less painful
to learn from others mistakes
no one domain or field has a lock on
wisdom
i've been astonished how much you can
learn if you read widely across a
variety of fields
i read as much as i can
find mentors
if you can identify people who have more
experience than you and who excel at
what they do it's incredible to have the
opportunity to learn from them
people love to teach others
if you're highly motivated and don't ask
for anything other than wisdom you can
learn a great deal
mentors have made a big difference in my
life
observe
a good friend of mine says people have
two eyes two ears and only one mouth for
a reason
there's certainly a lot to be gained
from watching and listening
when i travel i love listening to people
who have different life experiences than
i have
i learned so much from them
data and patterns matter a great deal
there's much to be learned from
analyzing the world
in investing and in life more broadly
i've found it's important to understand
things in terms of systems with various
inputs and layers of potential
effects i love statistics in school and
i've found that it along with psychology
may be the most under taught academic
subject with the greatest potential gain
to society for more people understanding
it
that being said not everything that's
important can be counted and not
everything that can be counted counts
as mark twain is alleged to have said
history does not repeat itself but it
does rhyme
in other words just because something
happened once doesn't necessarily mean
it will happen again in the same way
otherwise historians would be among the
wealthiest people on earth
so to understand the world you need to
pay attention to more than simply
memorizing a series of events or
existing patterns
judgment and wisdom matter a great deal
and both require experience and really
failure
unfortunately few of us learn much from
our successes
even if you make wise decisions
throughout your life you'll inevitably
make mistakes
in part this is because life is not like
a math problem with one perfect solution
a lot of decisions are inherently
probabilistic and the best you can do
much of the time is make a decision
that's likely to turn out in your favor
in fact the harder and more innovative
things you try to accomplish the more
likely you are to fail
that's just the reality
so when decisions ideas or new projects
don't work out try to learn and be
open-minded
also see whether you can sort out
whether the idea was flawed or whether
it was solid but the outcome suffered
from bad luck
it's tempting to ascribe things to poor
luck that were the result of your dumb
decisions
the opposite is also true sometimes you
can get wonderful outcomes from terrible
decisions
although it's incredibly hard to do it's
also useful to see if you can identify
mistakes you've made even when things
work out as well as or better than you
expect
to learn from your experience and the
experience of others it's important to
try to be dispassionate in looking at
the world and analyzing it
you need to be willing to try things you
think make sense and then to admit your
mistakes to throw away your beloved
theories and to learn from other people
this process requires a degree of
humility that's frequently lacking in
the world particularly among people who
have been successful
as the 19th century humorist josh
billings noted it ain't what we don't
know that gives us trouble it's what we
know that just ain't so
lake washington looking back towards
seattle
have dreams and work towards them
thomas jefferson said i'm a great
believer in luck and i find the harder i
work the more i have of it
success in my experience requires the
following elements
a clear stretch goal
if the goal is too easy it won't feel
like an achievement if it's unrealistic
you'll never do the work
love for what you're doing
very hard work often over a long period
of time
a sense of realism about the world and
your own limitations
as we used to say at microsoft you can't
boil the ocean
nor can you make people come back from
the dead
flexibility and perseverance you'll need
to adapt to the curve balls life will
throw at you
and often a bit of luck
people don't tend to achieve things in
great leaps forward
rather we progress one step at a time
usually with small insights here or
there
whether you're a scientist who builds on
the great work of others or a writer
whose work springs from the wisdom of
writers before you or an internet
entrepreneur whose innovations succeed
only because of a certain infrastructure
all this is possible only because of
small progressions from a massive
foundation of wisdom and experience
stretching into the distant past
we're all standing as isaac newton noted
on the shoulders of giants
similarly to make changes in your life
focus on taking small steps in the right
direction whether you want to change
your health your job or your
relationship you can't do it overnight
and you can't become great at anything
without a lot of repeated practice
be sure you're comfortable with taking
small steps then build on them
the initial change will be small and in
the near term the difference may be
imperceptible but as time goes on you'll
end up in a totally different place than
where you started
having run a marathon many years ago
slowly i think long distance running is
an excellent way to think about big
challenging goals
if you're out of shape and try to run a
marathon immediately you'll not only
fail but you'll probably seriously
injure yourself
if however you take small steps if you
slowly start walking then running short
distances then building to greater
distances over time it's likely you'll
find you can run a marathon
the same method works for just about
anything in life
faced with a big challenge you might get
overwhelmed or panic
you might even be afraid of succeeding
as a result you might not even try
but you can overcome these mental traps
by taking small steps and practicing
regularly
it also helps to imagine your success
the mind is an amazing thing
if you focus your brain on success and
you practice seriously you'll slowly
build the deep confidence you need to
persevere in life
you'll be ready for the obstacles the
world throws at you or at least you'll
expect to encounter them
and rather than panicking or freezing
next time you face a challenge you'll
continue to work toward your goals
over many years this type of approach
tends to build lasting progress and
ultimately success
you need to set the bar high enough that
achieving your goals will mean something
to you in the long term
and you should ensure that your goals
are at least broadly realistic
but you also should try to get on a
train going in the right direction
the internet provides some great
examples of the benefits of having the
wind at your back
if you want to be a journalist you're
likely to be far more successful over
the next 20 years if you focus on new
media versus trying to become a print
specialist
you're also likely to do better
designing graphics for the web than you
would for magazines and you're likely to
be more successful selling ads for
internet properties and mobile
applications than you would for
newspapers and tv
the skills and interests required to
succeed in these endeavors are similar
but if the field you enter is growing
your odds of success will be higher
i know people who have chosen both paths
even the most talented and hardworking
folks i've observed are constrained by
shrinking fields
so while you should pick something you
love first why not try to do that in an
environment that will help you succeed
simple things can cause complicated
outcomes both good and bad
persistent curiosity combined with
sustained focus on reasonable goals will
change your life over time
if you love what you do and work very
hard persevere and take small steps you
likely will be in a dramatically
different place 10 years from now the
same is true in your personal life
picking the right partner someone you
respect and with whom you can
communicate laugh and collaborate well
can make a huge difference in the
quality of your life
however like a career long-term
relationship success requires
perseverance and flexibility
people live happily ever after only in
the movies
no matter what your individual goals
hopes and dreams are i hope you start
immediately on your journey and keep
going
life is short
as benjamin franklin wrote you may delay
but time will not
epilogue if this book were even shorter
here's what it might say
albert einstein said everything should
be made as simple as possible but not
simpler
there are certain themes that run
throughout the book
it may be useful for some readers to
discuss them here
know yourself
to be happy you need to pay attention to
who you are what you want and how you
feel versus staying busy just doing
stuff or doing what other people want or
expect you to do
this requires both self-awareness and
introspection if you pay attention to
how you feel what you like and what you
want as well as what makes you feel sad
angry fearful and confused the world is
likely to look quite different
many people are afraid of being
introspective because they feel
vulnerable
but without a willingness to open up you
won't understand yourself and you can't
ultimately be truly happy
act on that knowledge
simply understanding how you feel and
what you want is vital but insufficient
progress depends on action
if your goal is to help other people but
you never do anything about it you'll be
unsatisfied
the same is true if you want to start a
business write a book invent some new
device learn to play an instrument get
better at a sport or be a good parent
remember take small steps
they work
big steps often don't
over time small steps add up and you end
up in a different place
observe it's incredibly hard to have a
dispassionate view of the world even if
you try your hardest
humans are emotional animals and we all
come at the world with our own point of
view based on our experience
it's impossible in many ways to get
outside that frame of reference although
with diverse experience a lot of reading
honest self-reflection on your failures
and some thinking it's possible to
stretch our perspective
data and patterns matter and you should
pay close attention to them
but they're not enough to deeply
understand the world since history
doesn't repeat itself exactly
judgment and wisdom matter a great deal
to acquire them and to be creative it's
important to slow down enough at times
to notice what is going on around you
focus
focus is important because time is
limited and you can't do everything let
alone do everything well
persevere
life doesn't come easily most of the
time to most of us
even if you have no major issues in your
life eventually you will
the way to succeed amidst obstacles is
to not give up
perseverance matters
i don't know anyone who has succeeded
over time in any field or significant
endeavor without it
manage change
change happens whether you like it or
not both in our personal lives and in
our world more broadly
with technology and globalization the
rate of change in society is
accelerating
being able to accept and manage change
is an essential skill
make friends
without true friends most of us wouldn't
enjoy our lives
to be happy it's vitally important to be
connected to other human beings whom you
care about and who in turn care about
you
care
if you don't take good care of yourself
physically and psychologically you won't
be able to enjoy your life
and if you don't care about others you
at least will be missing one of the
great joys of being alive
judgment matters
this is not a recipe book
many of these ideas conflict with others
for example you can't both create space
to let your mind wander and intensely
focus at the same time
you need to use your judgment to figure
out what's right for you at a given time
in your life
laugh
we're all going to be dead anyway
someday
so while you should try your hardest to
make the most of your life when
something funny happens when you make a
mistake or even and perhaps especially
when bad things happen it's easier if
you can laugh about yourself in the
world
afterward the world beyond us
woody allen said money is better than
poverty if only for financial reasons
this is a book about how to get the most
out of life
but i don't want you to think i'm some
sort of wild-eyed optimist who only sees
the positive in the world
we all have problems
people get sick
we die
we get rejected from schools and we lose
jobs
we fail at things we try to do
people disappoint us
relationships and marriages fall apart
some of us have financial troubles which
can spread into other areas of our lives
and on extremely rare occasions which
are far less likely to happen to you
than you'd think reading the news we're
impacted by random acts of violence and
terrorism
none of these things are fun many are
painful and some can be debilitating
still if you're reading this it's likely
you are lucky
there aren't many statistics in this
book but it might be useful to put the
world into a bit of context
at least eighty percent of the world's
population lives on less than ten
dollars per day or less than three
thousand six hundred and fifty dollars
per year
i don't know about you but i could not
imagine doing that
about one in four people in the world
lack electricity and one in six people
in the world don't have access to clean
drinking water nor can they read or
write or sign their names
by way of contrast i don't even think
about getting water out of the tap or
taking a shower
most of the world is not focused on a
second car or what certain hollywood
actors did in their personal lives
they would be grateful for a good meal
life is imperfect everywhere
there are real problems in the developed
world many of which you can read about
regularly in the press
the combination of record high levels of
unemployment and government debt is a
massive problem for citizens and
governments from the us to the eu to
japan
if you don't have a job and you both
want and are able to work life is hard
environmental challenges are also
growing as more of the world becomes
industrialized
the us is not leading in addressing this
challenge today but what happens in
places like china and india with their
nearly 2.5 billion people between them
may matter a lot more
weapons of mass destruction could in the
hands of fanatics severely impair
civilized life on earth
the odds of an event happening are quite
low but the consequences of such an
event could be catastrophic
education is another field that requires
focus as many people in our societies
aren't getting access to the sort of
educational opportunities that will
allow them to compete in the world today
let alone the world in which our
children will live in 20 years
the income gap between the stars of the
global technology driven economy and
average workers is growing in a way
which could lead to societal instability
over time
solving or even adequately addressing
these issues is not easy
solutions in a few areas may be unclear
and in other areas the solutions are
apparent but they require pragmatic
actions that will cause short-term
sacrifice
moreover most families have two parents
working outside the home an increasingly
challenging jobs with the result that
many people have more demands on their
time than ever before
and of course many households have
single parent families and they too have
increased pressures
that being said we in the developed
world live dramatically better than even
kings did hundreds of years ago
technology and innovation are rapidly
reshaping life in many ways
both forces have made the world a more
competitive place in many fields today
the competition for your job is not
simply coming from down the block or
across the country but from around the
world or from automation
few areas of the global
economy will be sheltered from these
forces and in fact it's likely that the
pace of change will only accelerate in
our lifetimes
there are risks to new technologies
including a potential loss of privacy
and various forms of abuse and fraud
however the same forces are also making
our lives more efficient more personal
and frequently easier in many ways than
they were even 20 years ago
job opportunities now exist in the us in
europe and in places like asia for
people who have never had them the rate
of innovation is rising everywhere and
inventions developed in other places
will help us all live better too
in addition global markets are now
larger for both individuals with
world-class talent and us and
western-based corporations
on a more personal level it's much
easier to buy things efficiently to
learn to rapidly find answers to
questions you may have to stay informed
entertained and stay in touch with your
friends no matter where they may live
there's promise on the horizon of major
advances in understanding the human
brain and genetics which would
significantly improve the quality of
life for people everywhere
and it seems likely in our lifetimes
that we will develop more efficient
greener energy sources which will help
power our civilization for many years
importantly we're free in much of the
developed world something which has not
been true for most of recorded history
for most people
while our lives are challenging and our
world has many issues some of which are
quite serious problems aren't new to our
times and there are also many great
opportunities
absent humans blowing each other up or
some sort of biological catastrophe life
is likely to be much better for our
children than it was for us